one of the like like vivid memories in
hip-hop history like high school in the
documentary
like the first time i heard how we do
was like that's what one of my favorite
songs ever and i just
like like how different would hip hop
have been had that
conflict never happened definitely crazy
movie
you know game had his reasons and uh 50
had his reasons
and you know um some of it might have
been business some of it might have been
maybe some reasons of selfishness and
through reasons of ego
yeah you know i really think that um it
was a situation
where it was teacher and student and i
think out of the whole
g-unit crew and you know shout out to
tony yeah that's a real
comrade of mine i think game was a
a teacher in the making you know what i
mean and if
somebody is going to come out of that
shell you can't keep them there too long
and then 50
being the general minded guy he is he
run his [ __ ] with an
iron fist so i think it was a clash
going on
and before 50 kind of realized it game
kind of scene that
it's this is going to restrict me right
right i got it i got to get away from
this and
and and that's how that went you know
what i mean but nevertheless
um it both gave hip-hop the substance we
needed
because hey 300 bars are running 50 50
50 allowed that
collaboration to happen and then through
it all
you know what i mean um they was able as
men
you know to kind of like come back
together and show that that mutual
respect
do you think like the jimmy henchman
like element of that
dynamic would like like like maybe added
to that
divide a bit well jimmy hinchman was
needed at the time you know what i mean
you got
pretty big as anything you can be into
ever i always say the two biggest
rappers of all time peak 50 and peak
snoop
that would that jimmy henchman element
was what gave
gamers edge because par roo was gonna
stand
behind him out here on the west coast
and then he had
part of his head security uh bounty
hunters two t's and bounty hunters and
uh
g magic from 88 avalon so it was a
mixture of everything we represented out
here standing with him anyway
right so that jimmy henchman element
kind of gave game the edge like that
extended clip because jimmy hinchman
was who he was in new york right so now
you look up and jimmy hintsman's
politics got game and a big ass
billboard in the middle of south side
queens
right and game lands in new york cause
he got to come to new york
jimmy henchman's squad is there to move
him around to protect him so
you know i don't jimmy jimmy did um
what he was supposed to do and he did
this [ __ ] well he did it great
you know and he stood with game um
as game still with him so i don't take
nothing from jimmy you know jimmy was a
solid dude
uh he got a situation himself over there
with some paperwork going
on and he gonna deal with that he got to
deal with that but what he did for game
um jimmy was hit right by him he did
right by